- Il reste 30 secondes au
décompte. Tikhon Dziadko
s'installe. La camera roule.
- L'émission est appelée
"Ici et maintenant".
- En régie, les intervenan
sont prêts et cadrés.
Le journalisme russe indépendant
a beau s'exercer en exil, il
est plus pertinent que jamais.
TIKHON DZYADKO, rédacteur en
chef, Dojd TV
- Je suis absolument sûr que
c'est une minorité agressive
i i i soutient la guerre, mais
pour le moment, ils possèdent
tous les moyens pour diffuser
l'information.
Comme en témoigne cet extrait
de la télévision d'État :
la vérité, les faits,
sont des concepts qui ont
complètement disparu du paysage
médiatique sous l'emprise du
Kremlin.
Et c'est la censure de toutes
voix opposées à la guerre
qui avait forcé la chaîne
de télévision Dojd, la
seule indépendante de Russie,
à quitter Moscou au printemps.
Il aura fallu des mois et
beaucoup d'effort pour relancer
ses activités depuis Riga.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est grâce à Youtube,
encore disponible en Russie,
et une licence de diffusion
fournie par la Lettonie que
jdjdjd a retrouvé sa voix.
La journaliste Maria Borzunova
est parmi les plus connues
de la chaîne. Appréciée pour
son franc parler, elle
se consacre à temps plein
à démasquer les mensonges
des autorités.
C'est avec des vidéos
de recrues enragés etdes témoige
Dojd réussit tous les jours à
capter l'attention des Russes.
14 millions de téléspectateurs
en Russie au mois de septe
et l'auditoire continue de
gonfler.
Elena, elle, appelle le Rost
et s'insurge du fait que
sa petite fille de 7 ans a
dû préparer des boîtes ivivivres
pour les soldats au front comme
activité à l'école.
- Jes s s que nous pouvons
faire plus que 14 millions.
Et aussi, je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de médias indépendants
qui travaillent maintenant
en exil.
- Beaucoup de jeunes, comme
Olessia, qui écrit pour le site
indépendant Holod.
Est-ce que c'est possible
pour une journaliste en exil
comme vous, russe, d'être lue
et entendue en Russie?
- Oui, mais c'est difficile...
- Olessia refuse de baisser
brbrbras, et tous le moyens
sont bons pour sensibiliser
son peuple.OLOLOLESSIA OSTAPCHUe
Holod Media
- Par exemple, moi, je
n'ai pas bloqué les gens avec
une position différente ou
avec une position problématique.
- Vous les écoutez, ces gens-là?
- Oui je les  écoute.
- Aussi douloureux soit-ilque de
ses compatriotes, elle sent
le vent tourner.
- Ils deviennent plus opposants.
- Que critiques?
- Plus critiques, oui.
- Mais il faut comprendre
que les gens en Russie pendant
plus que 20 ans ils ont été sous
cette pression de la propagande.
Il faut les soigner... Il faut,
il faut parler, parler et
parler parce que les gens,
ils ont beaucoup de doute.
- Aujourd'hui, le message du
Kremlin, c'est que les forces
ukrainiennes préparent une
bombe sale.
- Oui.
- Vous, vous adaptez comment
pour dire aux Russes qu'il y a
peut-être une autre histoire
derrière tout ça?
- Nous comprenons qu'il n'y a
pas de preuves, que le ministère
de la Défense, le ministère
des Affaires étrangères,
ils disent beaucoup de mots,
mais il n'y a pas de preuve.
- Et chaque jour, en Russie,
amène une nouvelle épreuve
avec une télévision d'État qui
est de plus en plus agressive,
voire criminelle, selon lui.
- Je pense qu'ils deviennent
de plus en plus animaux? Ils
disent des choses qui sont
absolument impossibles
à écouter.
otototre rôle est de dire
aux gens que si quelqu'un est
fou, ce n'est pas la normalité.
Ils sont fous. Dire, encore une.
- Vous voulez garder
leur sensibilité?
- Absolument!
- Si être russe à l'étranger
vient avec son lot de honte,
maintenir le dialogue avec
la maison est vital.PlPlPlus im.
♪ ♪